hey was geht ab jetzt bekommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut so dass man jetzt mir auch wenn
nur bisschen müde gerade bin gerade ist
von der uni nach hause gekommen muss
noch einkaufen deswegen trifft sich das
video auch gut und zwar habe ich das
schon länger in planung
ich möchte gerne so dumm ist sich jetzt
auch anhört könnte aber auch echt witzig
werden dass siri also dieser
sprachassistenten vom iphone sagt was
ich kaufen sollte mir ist es irgendwann
mal einen gefallen ich habe absolut
keine ahnung ob das funktioniert oder ob
man es dann irgendwie auf eine andere
art und weise lösen kann weil ich weiß
jetzt nicht wenn ich sage ja siri was
soll ich kaufen dass siri mir dann sagt
was ich kaufen soll ist ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich so weit sind wir auch
noch nicht von der techniker aber wir
versuchen es einfach mal wenn ihr die
idee auch so genial findet wie ich und
ich davon noch was machen soll dass auf
jeden fall jetzt schon fest die daumen
nach oben da und sie redet schon mit
kennen sie ich habe vor werden in die
die auch genial so öffnet die ich und
ich davon noch was laberst und das
klappt das schon super hallo siri hallo
lieblingsmenschen dass wir uns jetzt
kennen gut nenne mir einen supermarkt in
dem ich einkaufen soll
ich habe das hier geschult bisher um die
ecke oder ja es gibt hier viele märkte
zumindest einer von denen die um die
ecke sind ich piepst das jetzt mal soll
natürlich auch kein placement sein also
den markt haben wir schon mal gefunden
so leute ich bin jetzt hier auf der
website von dem markt den läden hier ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt verpixeln muss weil
er überall steht auch scheißegal auf
jeden fall bin ich jetzt hier auf
angebote seite das ding ist ich bin
eigentlich heller oder dunkler so ist
besser oder ich bin eigentlich fast
jeden tag einkaufen weil ich mir immer
für den tag dann sachen kauf also ich
gehe nicht einmal die woche einkaufen
sondern elfter deswegen machen wir jetzt
diesen teil ist ein kauf von mir ich
würde einfach mal sagen wir kaufen keine
ahnung acht verschiedene produkte und
was das sein wird das entscheidet sich
welches getränk soll ich kaufen alles
klar
zu welches getränk soll ich kaufen hat
folgendes ergebnis mir ein getränk ich
kann noch nicht dem aus deutschen in
eine andere sprache übersetzen
aber ich kann zwischen den sprachen
deutsch englisch französisch italienisch
mandarin chinesisch und spanisch
übersetzt
das habe ich mir gedacht funktioniert
halt nicht so wie es eigentlich wollte
deswegen machen wir es jetzt anders und
zwar steht hier jetzt getränke 20 siri
nenne mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 20
das ist 10 10 48 10 super gerolstein
moment linie plus limonade oder schulen
ja das ist ja echt gesund das schreiben
war sofort schon mal auf meinem zettel
ich bin auch wirklich so ich mag cola
echt nicht mehr gerne ich trinke lieber
schönen apfelsaft oder wasser das
erfüllt nämlich seinen zweck vielmehr
natürlich auch mal cola gerne zum essen
aber nicht mal so in der freizeit
irgendwie wir sind jetzt als nächstes
hier bei den süßwaren gelandet siri
abbrechen
kein kommentar gibt es etwas was ich ja
und zwar nenne mir eine zahl zwischen 1
und 9 7 134 50 abringen
echt günstig 129 ach so das sind alles
aktionspreise also wer jetzt als
nächstes pringles gut gesund ist das
jetzt nicht mehr aber es kommt natürlich
auch meinen einkaufszettel ciri brot
oder käse
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
recht hast du richtig verstanden brot
oder käse
es geht hier um dich spricht
wir lassen das so als nächstes sind wir
bei den top knüllern der woche wovon ist
da gibt es ganz schön viel
siri nennen wir doch mal bitte eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 70 das ist 71 da hat wohl
irgendwie in der schule nicht aufgepasst
kann das sein
ich bin mir nicht sicher noch nicht das
richtig verstanden habe okay wir nehmen
einfach die 71 ach du scheiße 48 12 64
68 und 31 23 golden toast mega bürger
hamburger oder hot dog brötchen ein euro
was soll ich dann noch mit na ja ich
würde sagen eine sache aus der kategorie
geht noch deswegen siri nennen wir doch
mal bitte eine zahl zwischen 1 und 100
wenn wir doch mal bitte eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 100
die antwort lautet nicht 101 eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 100 das ist 101 man nenne
mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 30
ich sage gar nichts mehr wir haben ja
eine steinofen pizza oder eine pizza
burger
ich schreibe mir einfach mal auf
steinofenpizza also viele sachen haben
wir schon mal und ich würde sagen an
sich ist die entscheidung gar nicht mal
schlecht könnte auch fast meinen
einkaufszettel sein wenn ich ihn selber
schreiben würde und siri private mal als
mal kurz was hier wirklich nichts gibt
es ja gar nicht auch immer ganz wichtig
wir sind jetzt hier bei obst und gemüse
mal sehen was da leckeres auf mich
wartet also siri nenne mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 16 und weil ich es nicht
gibt
19 anders was ich auch wirklich immer
richtig cool findet sind ganz klar hier
die top spieler der woche deswegen siri
zahl zwischen 1 und 12 aber zack zack
ich bin mir nicht sicher
zahl zwischen 1 und 12 nenne mir eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 12
meggle alpen butter joghurt butter oder
streich zahlt kann ich damit etwas
anfangen
ich glaube nicht mehr schreiben auf
merckle
menne mir eine zahl zwischen 1 und 20
lautet 1 schon wieder eins gut hast du
nicht im stand verkauft ja scheiße
egal das sieht gut aus dennoch muss ja
auch immer gut riechen ok 1 234 50 77
sachen kann ich davon gut leben wir
haben eine pizza wir haben anders wir
haben bringe ist ja ein apfel schule
wird schon passen also wie schon eben
gesagt das brauche ich nur immer für
einen tag morgen gibt es dann wieder
etwas anderes das macht wahrscheinlich
keiner von euch so dass er sich jeden
tag sachen kauft aber ich hatte
irgendwie eine zahl zwischen 1 und 5 das
ist sex nein ist es nicht nenne mir eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 5 grad esprit oder
einer fülle oder billmann del der 139
da kam dieses muster habe schon ewig
nicht mehr gegessen das kommt auch noch
mit auf die liste
ich wäre jetzt wirklich richtig
zufrieden nur eine sache muss ich sagen
ich hätte wirklich gerne brot und nicht
burger tus aber siri hat entschieden
wir gehen jetzt schnell einkaufen und
ich beneide ich im gesamtpaket echt
zufrieden also beschweren kann man sich
da normalerweise eher weniger deswegen
kommt mit ist gleich
[Musik]
so leute ich bin rallye war alles im
angebot und war günstig ich glaube 12
euro nur na dann herzlich willkommen
zurück ich habe mich eben noch kurz
umgezogen weil es recht deutlich wärmer
geworden ist also heute morgen war ich
habe das ganze leben aufgenommen per
video und habe einfach das ganze in
aufgenommen weil das ganze wirkt
eigentlich aufgehört das ganze in einem
sagt ich habe acht minuten gebraucht für
den ganzen einkauf und das ist echt sehr
schnell weil normalerweise finde ich die
sachen die ich brauche nicht alles was
irgendwie schon mal cool ist oder was
ich schon mal hatte sich und genau das
für sich brauchen finde ich nicht auf
den ersten blick und es gibt eine sache
die finde ich wirklich nie
und zwar ist das lebensmittelfarbe das
dauert immer so lange bis ich die
gefunden habe so egal jetzt hier die
ofenfrische für 19 90
wir haben eine ananas für da sind ganz
viele fliegen doch daran keine ahnung
zwei euro oder so wir haben die wm
pringles für 129 84 79 cent ohne band
selber brötchen für 1 euro esprit für
129 shampoo für 179 war im angebot aber
trotzdem echt teuer und diese geniale
butter die ich mir schon immer gewünscht
habe für 1 eur 59 von diese tüte hat
noch einmal 1500 extra kostet arbeit
vollkommen ok ist eine papiertüte die
sich zersetzt ich mag auch papiertüten
eigentlich lieber leute das war das
spontane video jetzt habe ich meine
sachen für die nächsten 24 8 eigentlich
noch länger shampoo kann ich lange
benutzen muss sowieso einen apfelsaft er
nicht im profisport mal fliegen hier
überall viel rum wegen der anderen aus
ich bin so dumm nur weil es aussieht wie
abgesagt muss es ja nicht gleich
apfelsaft sein limette ja das war's mit
dem video wenn es euch gefallen hat und
ihr sagt ey noch so ein paar oder keine
ahnung ich kann ja mal irgendwo siri
kann ja auch irgendwo bestellen
es sollte möglich sein dass man mit dem
google sprachassistenten sachen
bestellen kann du kannst den google
sprachassistenten sagen ja auch noch mal
ein friseurtermin für mich bestellen wir
das und das und der macht sowas ist
natürlich noch so next level aber man
kann ja ihr könnt ihr einfach mal eure
ideen was was hat dir für ideen was kann
sie mir bestellen schreibe es in die
kommentare ich bin sehr gespannt wir
sehen uns morgen wahrscheinlich wieder
gibt's neues video und bahrain